John welcome to Yale and thank you for
taking the time to participate in the
core course faith in globalization as
well as in this interview you're one of
the world's foremost expert in religion
and rights and this is what I would like
to talk to you about when one thinks
about globalization and human rights
some people say that human rights
language is kind of the new moral
language of planetary scope is that how
it strikes you as well I think that's
how it started it in 1948 when the
Universal Declaration was passed and
when the world was looking very
desperately to codify a new moral
language at the substitute for the
languages of Christianity enlightenment
and other faith traditions that had
betrayed themselves in the course of the
early part of the 20th century the world
had just stared into Hitler's gulags and
death camps the world had just been
through a war world war the world was
struggling to try to find some way of
delivering on the failed promises of
Christianity and enlightenment I
Christianity had promised the return of
Christ Christ had not returned the
Enlightenment had promised the withering
away of the state through the socialist
experiment that hadn't occurred the
Enlightenment it also promised a
heavenly city of reason that hadn't
occurred instead we had World War gulags
the Holocaust and the worst attalla
Terry disasters and in the history of
mankind and the world as a consequence
was looking for a new vocabulary to
think about the basic goods that had to
be achieved in a society the basic
rights that person could count on the
basic ingredients of what human dignity
reason conscience would ultimately
ensure and the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights was one way of codifying a
new moral language for the world
community and identifying the starting
point for a conversation about what it
means to live together as persons and
people's know the great upheavals that
you mentioned in the middle of the and
latter part of the 20th middle of the
20th century I have not replicated
themselves in quite the same the same
extent in the beginning of 21st but
nonetheless it's
very much a conflict-ridden 21st century
do you think that we continue to need a
kind of moral common moral language in
the global world today or are the more
impersonal processes replace some such
need I do think we still need a moral
language but i also think we need to
have implementation of the moral ideals
of that moral language i think we had 25
or 30 years of very prominent human
rights declarations in the 1940s to the
1960s and early 70s but what we move
toward now is trying to make those human
rights ideals instantiated on the ground
vindicated in local communities a part
of the culture of both of world
international relations but also of the
realization of rights on the ground
became important and I think in the 21st
century that the need for a universal
language which becomes a starting point
for dialogue and the need for providing
a ground at which parties can press
claims to both protect themselves to
receive entitlements that they haven't
received rights provides one such
vocabulary it can't be the be-all and
end-all of all vocabularies of moral
interaction it cannot substitute for the
kind of interstitial work that goes on
within families within communities with
the neighborhoods within churches within
other faith traditions but it is a
useful language to think about as a
starting point that people can hold in
common it depends though upon languages
of moral fervor that are maintained by
faith communities among others it
depends ultimately upon local political
and cultural and social conditions on
the ground to implement those ideals in
many ways Human Rights serves as serve
as middle axioms of our discourse
somewhere between the higher natural law
and other transcendent ideas that
religious and cultural communities
maintain but above the local communities
and their actions with respect to the
protection of persons and people's lives
properties and it provides a check on
excess at the local level and it
provides an instrument for the
implementation of ideals at the
transcendent level in lessons I think
Human Rights really is still useful
vocabulary but it can't be monopolistic
right but if one would it be correct to
say as some people have suggested that
were declaration on human rights to be
voted today in un I mean the 1948 one it
probably wouldn't pass have wouldn't
pass the world has become more complex
wide variety of processes have gone
going on and some of the some of the
rights enshrined in that in the
Declaration may not quite be as
universally shared it would that be is
that how you read the situation or
having made steady progress to
implementation of those those rights
where are we from 48 to today I think
the rights paradigm is it is as tenuous
today as it was in 1948 I mean there's a
wonderful story of Jacques Barrington
the UNESCO representative who
participated actively in the in the
formulation and ultimately the passage
at the Universal Declaration and after
the declaration was past 60 years ago
they interviewed in a media context
father Martin asked him oh how was the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
passed and with this great collection of
various cultures and religious
communities and intellectual traditions
represented at the table how ultimately
did you get this to pass and he said
well we could agree on the universal
declaration of human rights as long as
we did not ask why nothing that's of
telling comment about how tenuous the
human rights paradigm was in 1948 and I
dare say that persists in the ensuing 60
years and would persist to this day I
think one of the burdens of the human
rights movement is to be in ever
inclusive of new voices new values new
visions new ideals that were not part of
the discussion in 1948 the Asian
traditions the traditional religions of
non Abrahamic faiths were not actively
represented in the formulation of the
1948 Universal Declaration and those
communities have values and ideals that
I think have to be taken into account if
the human rights paradigm has continued
to have salience what human rights does
it provides communities in the West and
the non West with a mirror in which to
reflect
on their own values their own ideals to
see a normative totem and to see a
normative framework that allows them to
reflect upon their own faith traditions
their own cultural traditions their own
canonical statements about the good life
in the good society and oftentimes it
provides an alternative vocabulary that
is consonant with sometimes even goes
beyond and sometimes is has gone beyond
by canonical formulations in the
original texts and so when the Christian
tradition we have these wonderful
statements about what Christian freedom
means in the canonical statements of the
Quran and hadith there are wonderful
statements about embracing brothers and
sisters in the Jewish tradition about
covenant duty and responsibility of a
people before God these are alternative
ways of thinking about ideals that the
human rights paradigm articulates in
ball terms and that in many ways
provides a mirror to reflect on one's
own faith tradition you know presumably
one of the reasons for the pessimism of
some folks in terms of the possibility
of the passage of of the Universal
Declaration today has to do with precise
nature of the relationship between kind
of moral claims embodied in that
declaration and in the tradition of
human rights and religions and has
overarching interpretations of life they
sometimes at least some people say that
these are two or multiple competing
moral moral codes and the question is
which one has the altima see I think for
the individual person and his or her own
prayer closet certainly the faith
tradition has the ultimate primitive
superior superior claim on that person
and in many faith communities it's the
faith communities own canon in its own
treat its own cult its own code of
conduct that has to trump but in many
ways what human rights are are the are
the lubricant for non faith communities
political communities voluntary
associations and it provides a set of
basic starting points for how they
interact this person is a set of basic
ideals that they can claim for
themselves the language of Human Rights
can be cast as simply an Enlightenment
product
that privileges the individual over
community that privileges greed /
charity that privileges entitlement to
duty and there are certain formulations
of human rights in the history of the
West especially from the Enlightenment
forward that would lend themselves to
that interpretation and there are
certain provisions in the human rights
paradigm today that would seem to
privilege that kind of understanding of
human rights but the human rights
paradigm is very wide it's very varied
and has a variety of different
understandings of what it means to be a
person in community basic basic freedoms
of faith of speech of press of assembly
now these are not antithetical to faith
traditions these in fact are essential
to the exercise of those faith
traditions basic rights to provision to
work to welfare to respect to one's
dignity to a name to a home to the
sucker and sanctuary these are not these
are basic rights that are protected by
the human rights paradigm they are
consonant with Andy flow out of
religious traditions rather than
antithetical to them so there are ways
of showing overlapping consensus between
the moral languages implicit in the
human rights paradigm and the explicit
moral language is developed by a variety
of faith communities and I think is that
the overlapping consensus stage that we
have to engage in the question about
faith and freedom and how they work
together now this overlapping consensus
can happen also between the systems that
for particular communities hold
ultimately like religious various
religious groups who you you're right
that the human rights as such are not a
fundamental belief system it needed even
in this interview you have enlarged it
somehow as a middle axiom right could
you could you explicate that
relationship between between broader and
more overarching accounts of the good
life which may be religious traditions
and also represent and this human rights
and how they should be conceived in
regard to these yeah and in the Western
tradition which is where I spend most of
my time reading there's a classic
distinction between the net
tral law or used not to rally the common
law or the u.s. gentium and the civil
law or the u.s. Cavill a three layers of
legal authority with the highest being
the most transcendent the lowest being
the most local and malleable and
transient the natural law set forth
transcendent ideals transcendent norms
basic goods about life the civil law
implemented at the local level how one
governs one's local community given
local conditions and in between those
two there was the common law which is
the set of common things that people
have learned through trial and error
through experience reflections on nature
through the traditions of the elders and
and of their own communities and have
embraced as goods that the that can be
counted upon from community to community
that can be the basis for treaties that
can be the basis for understandings of
transnational or trans community into
cooperation interaction that classic
understanding of the u.s. gentium is is
it is was what was celebrated by the
seventeenth and eighteenth century of
formulators of the international law
first of the sea and then of trade and
of Alexa muratori and eventually of the
public international law human rights in
their modern instantiation are in many
ways ingredients the currency of that
you c-can't iam the the way of thinking
about how can we formulate crisply what
we hold in common as peoples not
hermetically that they can't be changed
and not as a substitute for for what we
formulate in our own faith communities
as the ideals but nonetheless is basic
axioms so protections of life
protections of Liberty protections of
property assurances of due process
assurances of no cruel and unusual
punishment protections of our of our
basic way of life could be formulated in
these human rights instruments and and
what the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights does in 1948 is gives us one
really powerful distillation of that the
same way that in 1789 and 1791 we
formulated a bill of rights which
consider
to be essential to the community of
America the various states competing as
they were nonetheless could agree upon
basic rights formulations and we you can
find other examples of ways of looking
at human rights as as capturing the
ideals giving freedom to the faith
communities to be able to pursue their
own ideals to have the free exercise
rights that they need to enjoy and to
articulate the norms of justice and
liberty and dignity that are critical to
and indeed essential expression given
essential expression in human rights
formulations but so so how does that
relate to the specific character of
those rights as human rights stayin in
here there are part and parcel of human
beings squawk human beings and therefore
universal and therefore one might expect
from some perspective well unchangeable
of kind of rock solid what I hear you
speak is that there's kind of the
history on the human rights how do you
relate these two I was interesting when
if you look at the history of Rights
development in the Western tradition
it's an instructive anecdote for example
that by 1650 every one of the rights
that becomes part of the u.s. bill of
rights of 1789 was already defended
theoretically formulated and fought over
by Protestants who were trying to
understand what does it mean to have the
right as a religious believer to freedom
of conscience and free exercise of one's
faith and what they what they began to
develop is to think about well we need
to figure out what are the grounds on
which we can articulate a basis for
revolting against the authorities that
are in place the authorities are vice
regions of God we have to respect them
but we cannot allow those authorities to
violate our core claims of conscience or
what are those well over time as as the
Protestant tradition you can do the same
story in other traditions as the
Protestant tradition began to think
about what are the essentials that we
have to have in place before that would
allow us
justify a revolt against an authorized
official a tyrant as we see it well
let's think about those well it's the
right to obey the Ten Commandments it's
the right to have the rights of religion
in the first table the rights of civil
community in the second table what are
they well as the rights to worship the
rights to be free from blasphemy rights
to be free from forced participation in
swearing oaths what are the civil rights
well the flip side of the Ten
Commandments it's the right to have our
family the rights to have our life their
rights to have our properties rights to
have a reputation there has to be free
from assault and as as they began to
think about other biblical foundations
on which they could formulate rights
claims Protestants then thought well
there are other ways of thinking about
Scripture what would he have we have
this formulation for example in the in
the New Testament that we are all called
to be prophets priests and kings but
what does that mean well it means among
other things that we have the right to
speak as a prophet we have the right to
worship as a priest we have the right to
rule and participate in rulers and King
began to look at the at the Hebrew Bible
and to look at formulations about
sanctuary about protection of the poor
about Jubilee began to think hard
through what that ultimately means for a
person's rights claim what Protestants
were doing in this micro example is
playing with their scriptural texts in
the exigency of the political moment how
to decide how to decide what is the
basis for revolt against a tyrant and
deciding what are the essential natural
rights that we have as humans quo humans
that would number one need to be
protected and number two would trigger a
revolt against the tyrant that would
violate those as fundamentals if you do
that same story in the Catholic
tradition from the 12th to the 18th
century in the Muslim tradition in the
various schools of jurisprudence that
emerged before the closing of the door
in the ninth century you do the same
thing and looking at covenant 'old
duties in the Jewish tradition you
ultimately have multiple ways by which
faith communities have looked at their
own canonical scriptures have looked at
their own faith traditions and decided
well these are certain fundamentals that
we can claim as humans and that we can
ultimately project upon all humans as
essential to their existence as persons
and if you put all that together you
they have a very thick what theologians
you theologians would call a theological
anthropology of human rights what does
it mean to be a human to be a human as
the canonical traditions have taught us
is to have a certain set of basic claims
that cannot be trespassed what human
rights in the 20th century are are in
many ways the distillation of those long
reflections some of which go back of two
millennia or more you have given us here
a kind of very very very brief and not a
compelling sketch about how religious
various religious traditions most
extensively in your narrative the
Protestant but obviously other
traditions as well has contributed to
the formulation of what we know now as
the human rights sometimes today people
claim that rights tradition is a secular
traditions religious folks often claim
that in order to differentiate
themselves from that from that tradition
how would you how would you describe the
kind of enlightenment sensibilities of
more secular type playing with
counterbalancing building on the
religious claims in the history of
development of human rights I think the
Enlightenment in part lives off the
capital of faith traditions prior to the
18th century that formulated rights in
particular ways the understanding for
example of the social contract in many
ways is a secular instantiation of
ideals about the social and political
and ecclesiastical covenants about which
the traditions have rich and deep
reflections the notion of human dignity
in some sense in its enlightenment
formulation is a secularized version of
the faith traditions understanding of
what it means to be the image bearer of
God the notions of the basic rights to
life the Liberty to property are in many
ways crisp summaries of long traditions
of religious thought that go into
formulating what does it mean for a
person to have life before God what does
it mean for the person have Liberty to
discharge the duties of the faith what
does it mean for the person to dress and
to keep the garden as a holder of
property the enlightenment lives off the
capital of a lot of those idea
and as I said to my anecdote a few
minutes ago there is a fairly crisp
summary of a lot of those rights
formulations in place already before the
indictment breaks out so somebody like
Locke who is a closet who is a cradle
Puritan who grows up in a in a thick
Anglo Puritan environment he's living
off the capital of a lot of those ideas
but the burden of the Enlightenment was
to try to find a way of formulating
those rights claims that didn't
necessarily depend upon the religious
languages from which they emerged and
part of that was born of necessity the
world was beset by a world by religious
warfare of various sorts the world was
beset by the constant tension between
Catholics and Protestants and then
warring sections within each of those
faith communities there was a very deep
question about the perennial pariah of
the Western tradition Jews and how to
incorporate them back into the into the
Western tradition there was the growing
conflict with Islam there was the issue
of what to do with indigenous peoples
encountered through colonization and
what the Enlightenment project was in
part was to say is there a way of
thinking about these traditional
normative claims that we call rights or
us or Libertas or freedoms in the
Western tradition in explicitly
theological ways and to formulate them
and abstract secular ways that didn't
necessarily depend upon a god hypothesis
didn't depend upon the thick faith
language that that was presupposed and
earlier formulation so they came to
share and they can be shared by out by
errors and they could be they could be
it could be the basis for treaties for
conventions for ways of understanding
that could be embraced by people of
various faith traditions or cultural
traditions and eventually become the new
nomenclature for the world order you
have to remember what the Enlightenment
was trying to substitute in the West was
what Christendom had provided for
centuries before and which the
Reformation ultimately broke up and
balkanized Western Christendom canon law
a universal Church in universal faith
one faith one territory one baptism had
been to 12th the 16th century paradigm
in the West it provided the language
was cast in rights terms but it was
exclusive in monopolistic in its
formulation 16th of the 18th century the
experience of the world was a fraction
balkanized world which could not live
with those faith claims in there
multiple formulations and the
Enlightenment in many ways captured in
its formulation of public private
international law and as well eventually
in formulations of rights ways of
thinking about living together as
persons in people's regardless of our
different faiths convictions and
eventually celebrating pluralism and
making it the natural check and balance
against the excess of monopolization or
establishment of one any one faith
tradition I mean Madison's fav and
famous Federalist paper number 10 where
he celebrates factionalism what is the
point of that the point of that is to
say look let a multitude of flowers
bloom let a multitude of factions war
with one another let a multitude of
faiths in coexist in a community and
they'll provide quote a sensor moorim on
the other keep one from becoming
monopolistic over another and then
ultimately putting in place an
Establishment Clause in the first
amendment that would ensure there was a
legal protection if that natural
check-and-balance didn't work so it's an
ingenious an ingenious way of trying to
make the best of a tough world order in
the 18th century and eventually but it
eventually becomes a technique of coast
con sociation which is work for two
centuries since in a sense of challenge
today is what has been done for the
Western world to do in a different
registered for the world world as a
whole that's exactly right and right
that's exactly right that's the big as
the huge challenge that worldwide
science worldwide economy worldwide
media worldwide literature and
increasingly world law and world Human
Rights has to achieve and I think that's
the big burden on us in a 21st century
is defined to find a language to find a
set of institutions a set of normative
practices a set of mutual expectations
that everyone around the world will take
for granted and it's very hard when
Dharma some of the starting premises
namely self-preservation preservation
one's own life is now being blown up in
and various kinds of suicide bombings
it's very hard to presume a common
obligation of stewardship where we would
think that the last thing we want to do
is to destroy the world around us and
where that is still contested in various
parts of the world it's very difficult
to do that when certain starting points
about gender parity or that or the
preciousness of the life of a child or
other basics that we're presupposed
sometimes not even articulate
presupposed in the rights formulations
of the 18th century are still very much
up for grabs but it's interesting you
say some of these some of these things
are of course coded in religious terms
some of these differences right and at
the same time you say but from my
perspective I think rightly that we also
need religious traditions the rights
languages need religious traditions and
vice versa that religious traditions
need rights rights language could you
explicate that that relationship between
the between the two why does one need
the other and does so in a very much a
globalized world in which we are
searching for these kind of common
language and common institutions the
easier one is why religion need human
rights and just ask the persecuted
religious believers in various parts of
the world are being slaughtered by the
tens of thousands but by reason of their
faith convictions and appreciating
freedom of conscience basic freedom of
exercise basic assurance of procedural
rights basic protections of their groups
identity basic ability to have
collective property to bury their dead
to educate their children those rights
can't be taken for granted around the
world today and religious persecution is
real it's palpable it's tragic and in
many ways human right religious
communities need human rights gear and
key to them as a universal in order for
that kind of tragic and sometimes
outrageous behavior to end and to
provide a at minimum a basis for
mobilizing shame against those
would persecute if not providing grounds
for pursuit of lawsuits and other kinds
of political remedies to offset the the
tragedy that besets a lot of those
communities around the world and
religious persecution is unfortunately
alive and well in this world today we
don't hear about it on the front page of
papers but it's a it's a huge issue and
it's not just people in rwanda burundi
our church etnia it's in many places of
the world or 130 major civil wars going
on and many of those religious factors
are an important part of the prejudice
and the persecution so I think that side
is relatively easy the flip side is a
harder one why does Human Rights need
religion part of that is an argument
about religion and religious rights are
the conceptual in the historical source
for many of the rights that we hold dear
today the right of the individual to
believe and to exercise his or her
belief leads ineluctably to the rights
to speak to worship to associate to
travel to parent to educate this and to
participate in one's religious community
on the basis of one's religious beliefs
for the end for the religious group the
right to exist leads to the rights to
corporate property to corporate
organization to organize charity to
parochial education to a variety of
other basic rights attached to religious
communities religion provides oftentimes
a starting point especially in
transitional democracies for the first
rights that get protected that
eventually give rise to the to the
complementary and correlative rights
that are essential religion is also an
important check upon the limitless
expansion of human rights many religious
communities claim rights not just in the
abstract but claimed rights in order to
discharge the duties of the faith rights
and duties and those religious
communities belong 2gether rights
without duties and quickly become claims
of self-indulgence duties without rights
quickly become sources of deep guilt
rights and duties are organically
connected and by religious communities
are often the best stewards for showing
the necessary connection between the two
and then putting limits on rights
expansion to simply
whimsical wants and wishes I didn't so
right certain rights are pets its claims
for myself all right religious
traditions situate those rights is it to
care for rights for others as well look
swollen self exactly there and it's the
duties to oneself to one's faith to
one's faith community ones family opt me
to one's God and the Christian tradition
it's the right to discharge the duties
of love to God neighbor and self that's
really what faith communities help
rights articulate for themselves the
third thing in that and that is that
religious communities often are the
institutions especially again in
transitional democracies that help to
vindicate rights you can't depend upon
the state as the only protector and
guarantor and Vindicator of rights in a
lot of communities around the world
because we tell yourself over against
the state right yeah often against the
state and often often prophetic
prototypical of what the state needs to
do I mean if you think about religious
communities in especially colonial
autocracy or inadequate and colonies or
in nitocris ease in the 1970s through
90s religious communities really are the
zones of liberty they are the place that
provides some of the prototypes for the
first generation Civil and Political
Rights they are often the communities
that provide a principle if not the
exclusive means to vindicate
second-generation rights of health care
and education and charity artistic labor
and other opportunities and religious
communities provide some of the deepest
ingredients and understandings of
creation of stewardship of trustees ship
and of servanthood that lie at the heart
of what we call third generation writes
a peace order orderly development and
Environmental Protection so religious
communities are essential allies and
then you can think about religious ideas
as in many ways thus they set the scale
of values and the sources of values
which improvement rights community
presupposes religious communities
provide that the sources of restraint
and respect of protection for the other
for the vulnerable provide ingredients
and examples of accountability and
responsibility that a human rights
regime ultimately presupposes and needs
in order to be made real and in that
sense religious communities
because they are so Natalie intersected
in public and private life because they
are an erratic in a radical condition of
human communities religious communities
have to be dealt with and human rights
communities that pretend that religious
communities can simply be either
dismissed to the private sphere or
religious rights activists that talk
about religion being a silly
superstition that's eventually going to
going to die a slow death and and simply
be consigned at best to the hobbyhorse
of the person that's contemplating life
in the hereafter that understanding of
religion is in many ways been betrayed
by the last 30 years of this new great
awakening of religion around the world
religion has to be dealt with because
it's their their perennial e pervasively
profoundly and it's essential in many
ways in providing the scoop the sources
and scales of values that human rights
communities presuppose in the
vindication of their rights and would I
be right to say that precisely these
consideration as well make you argue
that religious rights are particularly
significant to protect the protection of
religious right is a special case of
protection of rights maybe I understand
that in and it's and that's captured in
article 18 of the Universal Declaration
which has a set of basic guarantees of
freedom of conscience and freedom of
exercise the ability to choose and
change when religion the ability to
organize oneself in religious
communities to have the special
exemptions and needs and immunities of
those communities respected by nation
states that sign on to the universal
declarations values those views are
elaborated in 1966 Covenant on Civil and
Political Rights there's a further
guarantee in article 26 of the 66
covenant about the need to ensure that
communities do not engage in
discrimination based on religious
grounds among others religious rights
simply provide the ability for the
individual and the group to
exist and to exercise their faith keep
their faith convictions singly and in
community together and in what those let
those basic rights are are elaborated in
some detailed in 1981 UN declaration on
religious intolerance that has you know
eight fairly thick provisions about what
goes into a religious rights protection
and they began a concluding document
1989 gives further corporate free
exercise examples now you you seem from
from the from the tenor of this
conversation you seem hopeful about the
future of human rights in our globalized
world maybe even hopeful about creation
of common institutions in the globalized
world but the first hopefulness is
essential essential virtue what do you
think we can concretely do to stimulate
whether we are academic or activist in
order to stimulate more vigorous
discussion as well as implementation in
particular of human rights across the
globe so as to provide the kind of
environment in which we would be able to
live a stable and peaceful life there's
no substitute first of all for
protecting the rights of people on the
ground that have not had those rights
protected two-thirds of the world suffer
fundamental rights violations everyday
and fundamental rights to food to
shelter to basic Liberty to gender
equality to protection of their children
to access to health care to basic
procedural due process rights the first
and foremost way of making Human Rights
an ideal that is real for many people is
to show on the ground in practical
application what that means secondly I
think it's very important for us to
understand that human rights are not the
product of the Western enlightenment
that human rights are not the privileges
of liberty to the exclusion of Duty not
the not the triumph of the individual
over the community not the triumph of
greed over charity but in fact human
rights are simply one way of talking
about
on the good life in the good society and
how it can be achieved and the more we
can show that there are multiple ways of
thinking about human rights the more we
can show the deep historical sources of
human rights in a variety of faith and
cultural communities the more we can
show analogs in other faith communities
outside the West that have ideals values
canonical prescriptions normative
practices that are consistent with
sometimes go beyond human rights I think
the better position will be deep will be
third I think it's very important that
in the 21st century we continue to press
on the institutional structures that
will make rights real at the trans
national level the United Nations
various regional in serious regional
institutions that are out there continue
to be relatively weak bodies they
continue to depend upon cojen see the
charisma and other ingredients for
effective enforcement if we're going to
make this real in a 21st century world
rights are going to depend upon a world
political community and a world
political community that's more than
simply an extension of the whims of the
five superpowers or three superpowers or
one superpower that might be in place at
one given time and increasingly I think
that obligates us to take very seriously
the emerging superpowers of India and
China that are that are verging in the
global economy and that eventually are
going to be part of the infrastructure
of any kind of world understanding of
what political responsibility means I
think fourth and finally I think what's
important is that to do the exercise
that I mentioned a few minutes ago that
faith communities cultural communities
have to use the human rights paradigm
today as a mirror in which to reflect
upon themselves as a way of mobilizing
shame against falling short of its own
ideals as a way of thinking about how
their own ideals their core
understandings of peace and fraternity
of brotherly and sisterly love and
affection that are at the core of every
religious community can be realized and
new in this way of thinking about what
human rights are and what are essential
to our human nature in our human society
Andy and to find ways of translating
their own cultural canonical and
religious understandings of the good
life in the good society into terms that
can be understood by insiders and
Outsiders alike the human rights
community has to be open to that it has
to be open to new formulations of the
good life and the good society that go
beyond what the Universal Declaration in
its progeny is produced the intern these
religious communities have to develop
their own internal religious
hermeneutics hermeneutics of Human
Rights hermeneutics of confession
showing how they've fallen short
hermeneutics of suspicion not simply
capitulating to any one particular
formulation of human rights and then
hermeneutics of history going back to
their own traditions and reclaiming
their own voices values of the human
rights dialogue Joan thank you for this
very stimulating conversation and thank
you especially for the challenge at the
very end of that conversation let's hope
that we can take it on and achieve a
greater measure of peace grounded in
respect for human rights I think I'm
good to be here thank you